hey guys welcome to max tech i've been
using and testing the iphone 13 pro max
for just about two weeks now and
although this is by far the most happy
i've ever been with an iphone due to it
just being so polished there are still
some software and hardware problems that
i'm going to be discussing in this video
as well as the solutions to some of
those problems so let's get right into
it the first problem has to do with
overheating issues which can cause the
display to dim down which are the same
issues we had before with the iphone 12
pro max for example max the other main
host of this channel was doing some real
estate drone videography yesterday with
his iphone 13 pro as the display
for his mavic air 2 drone and he found
that after only a few minutes out in the
sun the display dimmed down to 50
percent of the maximum brightness making
it difficult to see the display and it
wouldn't even recover now this issue is
likely due to being out in direct
sunlight while requiring high brightness
to see the display and actively using
gps to track and control the drone now i
do want to mention that the dimming
issues aren't nearly as bad as last
year's 12 pro max which dimmed down to
an extremely low level probably twice as
dim as the 13 pro max but it still sucks
to see that we have to deal with dimming
like this now i also want to mention
that this doesn't just apply to drone
videography because tyler stallman a
photographer who runs a youtube channel
also noticed that the 13 still dims
while taking photos out in the sun but
thankfully not as bad as a 12. but with
that said we actually did find a fix for
the display dimming problem and that is
low power mode which clocks down the
speed of the a15 bionic chip so it uses
less power and produces less heat so max
tested his drone out one more time
except now with low power mode turned on
and the brightness manually turned down
to 80 percent and after 15 to 20 minutes
of using his drone outside he didn't
experience any dimming at all and was
able to use his drone without any issues
even without having to go into the shade
and to turn this mode on just go into
your settings app go to the control
center then tap the plus icon next to
low power mode then bring down your
control panel by pulling down from the
battery icon and then simply tap on the
low power mode icon to turn it on now
getting into the second problem with the
13 pro max this one has to do with the
software ever since i got this phone
i've noticed an issue where sometimes my
touch inputs don't seem to register
causing me to have to tab multiple times
to get into a link and for some reason
i'm mostly experiencing this issue
within the youtube app when i try to tap
on videos and they simply won't load
until i move the display around and come
back to the video now i do want to
mention that i experienced this issue
with my 12 pro max while running ios 15
beta software so i'm convinced that it's
an issue to do with ios 15 but even
after updating to the latest ios
15.0.1 update i'm still getting this
touch input reliability issue so here's
a quick tip on how to deal with this
until apple gives it a proper update
just scroll down slightly and tap in a
different location which works for me
sometimes now getting into problem
number three this actually has to do
with the cameras on the 13 pro and the
pro max the new macro mode is definitely
an awesome addition because it allows
you to take photos that were never
possible before on an iphone allowing
you to get much closer than you can on
iphones without this new feature but
there's actually a pretty bad problem
with the macro mode specifically when
you start getting closer to an object
the system automatically switches to the
macro lens for you without letting you
manually choose the lens yourself but
the even bigger issue is that it
switches to that macro lens way too soon
because it tries to keep the transition
looking smooth so it actually uses a
digital crop on the ultra wide lens so
it matches the composition but then if
you tap the 0.5 x button it reveals just
how much digital crop it was adding to
make it look like a smooth transition
but that digital crop is ruining the
image quality for those who didn't
really want to get super close to the
subject and just snap the photo at a
medium distance so if apple allowed you
to switch the cameras manually perhaps
to the telephoto lens the photo would
end up turning out much nicer at that
medium distance but thankfully there is
a way to solve this issue until apple
releases an update you actually have to
physically cover the ultrawide lens with
your finger allowing you to choose the
other lenses to take a shot like the
telephoto which gives you more
background compression getting into
problem number four the camera system on
the 13 pro sometimes chooses to use the
telephoto lens for low light shots when
it really shouldn't be during our
unbiased camera comparison between the
13 pro max and the s21 ultra we took a
photo in very low light and the iphone
did much worse than the samsung that's
because the iphone chose to use its 3x
telephoto lens to take the shot while
the s21 ultra actually cropped in three
times on the main camera which obviously
looks much better now the reason for
that is because the main lens has a much
faster aperture which lets in much more
light so cropping in three times on the
main lens actually looks better and the
worst part is that on the latest iphone
13 pro and pro max the 3x telephoto lens
now has an even slower f 2.8 aperture
than the telephoto lenses on the 11 and
12 pro max which can actually cause
nighttime photos to look less detailed
because it's taking in less light so it
seems as though the software thinks that
using the 3x lens and those dark
scenarios will give you more detail but
it doesn't so users who don't know
what's going on are gonna end up with
noticeably worse photos compared to
someone who does understand all of this
and will know that they've gotta switch
to the main lens to get the best quality
especially since the main lens supports
night mode portraits combining both of
those features and speaking of night
mode the 13 pro is the first iphone
which supports night mode directly on
the telephoto lens but the major issue
is that because of the slower f 2.8
aperture the photos can actually turn
out worse than the 11 and 12 pro max
which use a crop of the main lens and
that is because the slower aperture
means that you have to wait longer for
the sensor to gather light and the
longer you have to wait the more camera
shake gets added to the image as well as
the movements in the subject itself like
these swaying trees that end up looking
a bit blurry so if you're going to be
shooting night mode photos with the
telephoto lens i actually recommend
zooming out a slight bit from 3x to 2.9x
zoom forcing it to use the main lens
instead which actually ends up looking
better than the telephoto lens now the
fifth problem has to do with gaming
especially for games that are more
graphically intensive i've been testing
out multiple games like call of duty
mobile pokemon unite league of legends
wild rift pubg and genshin impact and
most of these games run fine without any
display dimming and overheating issues
but i started to notice some dimming in
pubg and then a bunch of dimming and
gentian impact since it's the most
graphically demanding ios game out there
specifically it would dim down to just
over 50 brightness after only 5 to 10
minutes of gameplay at maxed out
settings now these results are
definitely improved compared to the 12
pro max which would dim much more and
after a shorter period of time but still
it sucks to see that apple just can't
keep the a15 chip cool enough to avoid
these display dimming issues however we
discovered a fix using low power mode is
actually a viable option for gaming so i
ended up making a full video testing an
hour of gaming both with and without low
power mode being enabled and i
discovered that you'll save a ton of
battery life without sacrificing
performance since it's stuck to 60fps
for the four games that we tested and
then in generation impact low power mode
allowed the iphone to last a full 20
minutes before dimming to the 50
brightness level compared to only 5 to
10 minutes without low power mode
enabled now the only issue with this
mode is that it actually limits the
display refresh rate from 120 hertz down
to a maximum of 60 so you essentially
wouldn't be able to use it if you wanted
to play games at 120fps for example i
played pascal's wager at 120fps and the
phone dimmed like crazy after only a few
minutes because of the massive graphics
load of trying to draw so many frames so
apple definitely needs to add better
cooling to the a16 chip next year to
solve this problem but for 60fps games
low power mode is a must and if you're
experiencing display dimming issues you
can try to start your gameplay session
off at 80 percent or lower brightness to
reduce heat and you can also try turning
down some of the graphics settings in
your game as well problem number six
brings us back to the cameras
specifically the cinematic video
recording mode first off just the fact
that it's limited to 1080p instead of 4k
means that i'm basically not gonna want
to be recording in this mode because i'd
rather have the much better 4k footage
and since the blur edging is still a bit
rough around the edges you kind of have
to turn down the blur amount to make it
look more natural but then the other
problem is that this mode is locked into
30fps recording which honestly is a bit
weird since many cinematographers use
24fps video recording including most
movies in fact almost every single video
we shoot on this channel is shot at 24
fps with the only exception being our
60fps gaming comparison videos which are
shot that way to show differences in
frame rates while gaming so apple really
should have given us a toggle to at
least switch between 24 and 30 fps for
those who want it but unfortunately they
didn't getting into problem number seven
apple did reveal the prores video
recording feature which ups the bit rate
to give cleaner looking video footage
but there are some big problems with
that first off since the file sizes are
so large specifically 6 gigabytes per
minute for 4k recording you need at
least a 256 gigabyte model to be able to
record at 4k but making it worse the
iphone still packs a lightning port
which is extremely slow at transferring
data since it uses the old usb 2.0
standard now michael tobin who got an
exclusive first look at the iphone 13
pro's prores video recording feature
said it took him an hour and a half to
transfer almost 200 gigabytes of prores
clips using the lightning port which is
extremely slow for only around 33
minutes of footage much lower than usb
type c speeds now michael does recommend
using the image capture app on a mac to
transfer the clips because it transfers
one clip at a time so if anything fails
or you need to unplug it it's not going
to ruin the entire transfer like it will
on the photos app now finishing off with
problem number eight the iphone 13 pro
max is missing a very important feature
that android phones have had for years
ever since they switched to oled
displays yes that's the rumored always
on display feature that people thought
apple would be adding ever since the
first oled iphone 10 but no and now with
apple finally giving the iphone 13 pro
an ltpo display capable of refreshing
from 10 hertz all the way up to 120
hertz people thought that we're finally
getting this feature on this iphone
because it's the perfect time to add it
but for some reason apple didn't and to
make things even worse there are no
excuses left because the display is now
25 more efficient than the one on the 12
pro and on top of that the battery life
in these new iphones is insane but apple
simply chose not to add always on for
some reason so my only guess is that
apple intentionally left this feature
out to make the next iphone seem better
or maybe they just didn't think it was
polished enough to add it with this
phone so there you guys go those are the
top eight problems that we've had with
the iphone 13 pro and if you have any
more to add then go ahead and comment
them down below and if any of those tips
helped you out then click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check those two
videos out right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you